and so it it makes us narcissistic
almost because we think the whole world
revolves around us
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wifed by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and he realized i'm
actually very regular regular i'm
nothing special
okay
but what class of women are you talking
about like how intellectual are they
where do they come from what are women
or you think all women think like this
most women yeah
would you think they think they're about
i think they should yeah because you get
the dating app data which allows women
to be very honest and women only swipe
right five percent of the time
men are ugly in pictures laura no women
find 80 no no women find 80 of men
unattractive not uh okay like
unattractive but what about in person no
just anywhere anywhere yeah eighty
percent of men they find unattractive
but because i've spoken to them or
because on face value that like there's
something chemically that they're like
because they've had better sexually and
they're just their standards are skewed
yeah so a lot of a lot of times i'll
hear girls say things like oh he's
medium ugly and i'm like no sis that's
your level
but you know that term you've heard it
right
oh you've never had medium you're not on
social media right yeah i'm snapchat
because only 20 of men are actually
having sex 20 yeah so one out of one out
of three men either are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year
and that's the trend so that's the trend
that's going going on the last like 50
years where it's like 50 years yes
slowly it's a bigger and bigger
percentage of men aren't having sex so
but if most women are having sex that
means they're having sex with the same
guys
that's like why do you think women say
things like men are trash all men cheat
dead
because they're all sleepy funny
no it's but it's serious because
everything funny has a little bit of
truth in it right but it's because we're
dating the same ones
um
so for the past 50 years
only 20 of men have been having sex
is that right look at that
roughly yeah yeah
so prior to that
more men were having sex because women
were less free
in a way yeah because because we had
more we had we had to vet men more
because we could possibly get pregnant
because birth control is a fail-safe
right if you get if you get an iud you
have like a 99 chance of not getting
pregnant okay so that's a fail-safe and
if that doesn't work you can get an
abortion
now oh i'm sorry there's a there's a box
um
but and so they we had to prioritize a
man that was going to stick around okay
and typically like we got married
younger and the men around us vetted the
men around us like our fathers would vet
guys before we would go on dates with
them and stuff and like women we're kind
of dumb like a guy can sweet talk us and
like
yeah
like we're not
you know what it's like
because you know it's true right
and so but men vet men better because
they can tell you when someone's like
talking [ __ ] to you
because if a guy's smooth he had to
practice to get there boy guys aren't
just born smooth
i mean sometimes
they don't want to hear it like i have
female friends that will ask me stuff
um about the way guys are acting and you
tell them and they
they're still okay with what's happening
because they'll still like
go along with
the game that he's playing because
deep you probably know it's a game but
you're enjoying it
and you want you want him to laugh
i think i think they just see um
i think they just see potential
they go
the game's happening hopefully he's
going to change
um i want him to change and
he'll change for me because
he's with me he's here and
this is what i want so it's the delusion
in them selfish in
some regards but it is what it is and a
lot of women their attraction is is
they take their ideas from other women
they want the guy that they're they're
going after to be validated by other
women and that's what part yes and she
realizes he's the alpha within this
group
and where it changes revolutionary
previously it might have been
um
say being able to be a fighter being
able to protect now it's about wealth
high value status within your echo
chambers or the values you respect yeah
you need other women importantly women
that you respect for example the the
commodity in the sexual marketplace as
women is her looks other women that you
recognize as pretty to also have a
vested interest in this guy and that's
how random win the game
why do you think um
why are women grossed out at dirty jokes
but the same women do those things in
the bedroom
because they don't
because they don't want to seem like
they do that they don't it's like the
stigma that they have oh i don't want to
seem like a like a [ __ ] but in the dark
they're like [ __ ] me out let's let's let
me like
it's just
it's just that like image that they want
to keep and so
it's it's crazy it's like if you do it
just own up to it and just
if they did that a lot of men value
purity
yeah
men would be attractive if she was to
say like yeah i like the car key on my
face i think it's the same
like body count so yeah are you talking
about like with the with friends or like
if a dude said that dirty joke to them
they were like oh no i don't do that
yeah i don't know it's just a question
okay
yeah i think what friends they
they don't seem with friends they
trust both with men's and friends they
hide it
and they don't like tell i think with
men they do it more
it gets to a point with friends like
maybe a friend will say and i've had
this in my friend group they'll say
something like they did to
what they're doing and they'll be like
oh she's she's crazy too she's a freak
in the bedroom too i can say what i what
i did as well and then there'll be like
a conversation of what they did and it's
like an openness once they find out that
one girl is just as crazy yeah they'll
be like okay i can find comfort in this
group now but with dudes i don't
i don't think open up
yeah
so i have a question for the guys
so you you said that body count doesn't
matter so much to you
in the context of what we're asking yeah
so so question how many bodies is too
many bodies how many bodies is too many
bodies
damn i have to give a hardline response
of understanding you could say plus or
minus like you know roughly
i think the age i'm at now
mid to late 20s
i think anything in the in london
because everyone will lie about the body
count i know where the people are on in
school
below 10 is good
10 to 15
is okay and then below 20 is like
you wouldn't agree with it but you'd
accept it because i've come to realize
having done numbers myself
[Music]
so many people lie that is
is yeah and especially i've got one
thing i've come to the realization as
well
is that cool say at one point i was
chopping out and going through but the
reality is
is these same women were probably
getting chopped out by guys like me who
were just time wasters
so probably from what i'm attracted to
is like echo chambers like i could go to
for that nerdy girl who plays chess and
her body counts probably below free
but then like if i tried to put my thumb
in her bum she might be like whoa what's
going on so what's that jesus
that would be telling them already
or she might not she might be on she
might she might be on it she might be
like she might be on it
king